des dons ville au milieu des grandes
cultures beauceronne gourmande sans
produits chimiques
voici la jardinerie delbard entreprise
familiale 35 employés 6000 mètres carrés
où viennent aussi se servir les
agriculteurs voisins ici et ne
trouveront plus de traitements chimiques
pour leur jardin
le rayon déjà très réduits depuis deux
ans est désormais vide plus de chimie
qu'en pense sa clientèle
elle prend c'est avec inquiétude les
gens ont besoin d'être rassurés ils ont
peur de pas avoir de solution pour leurs
jardins et c'est un changement
d'habitude donc on n'aime pas trop
généralement changer ses habitudes et
donc c'est à nous entre guillemets de
convaincre nos clients qu'il y a des
solutions et qu'on est là pour leur
proposer
c'est valérie comme qui depuis plusieurs
années vous propose des solutions
alternatives
et il y en a à foison pour le désherbage
bien sûr à la place du glyphosate contre
les ravageurs et les maladies
là vous avez tout ce qui est produits
phytosanitaires donc notamment tout ce
qui est un scepticisme ou là on va
retrouver vraiment des produits naturels
notamment tout ce qui est bacillus
thuringiensis donc c'est une molécule
qui est connu notamment contre la pyrale
du buis
mais on peut l'utiliser aussi contre
l'ensemble des chenilles qu'on a au
niveau du jardin pour tout ce qui y est
pucerons ou on a une gamme de huile de
colza par exemple qui va permettre
d'avoir un plus large spectre au niveau
d'autres insectes
ça restera tout aussi efficace qu'un
chine la différence c'est que là il faut
aller plus régulièrement dans son jardin
mieux observer et de façon à traiter un
peu plus préventivement que curative
mans pour cette entreprise familiale
avec cette interdiction de la chimie il
s'agit juste de continuer à creuser un
sillon amorcée depuis plusieurs années
avec l'aide d'une association qui oeuvre
surtout le loiret loir et nature
environnement